نصف انفرازه لاحت في افقي العلاقات
التركيه مع مصر مع تصدر مصافحه الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لنظيره المصريه
عبد الفتاح السيسي كانت مصافحه على هامش
افتتاح كاس العالم في قطر في العشرين من
نوفمبر لكنها وصفت بالتاريخيه ايضا صوره
فتحت بابا كان قد اوصت ربما بين البلدين
ما يعني ان التطبيع العلاقات او ربما
تصحيحها بتيلوح في المدى القريب جمله
تصريحات تركيه لا تبعد عن كونها مؤشرات
تقارب واضحه وصريحه اردوغان قال ان عمليه
بناء العلاقه مع مصر ستبدا باجتماع وزراء
من البلدين وان المحادثات ستتطور انطلاقا
من ذلك وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاويش
اوغلو ايضا اشار الى ان الدولتين ستانفان
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه باكملها وان كلا
منهما سيعيد تعيين السفراء في الاشهر
المقبله حتى المتحدث باسم الرئاسه التركيه
ابراهيم كالين ذهب الى ابعد ان ذلك او الى
ابعاد اكبر بالاحرف موضحا ان هناك احتمالا
لعقد قمه تركيه مصريه بين الرئيسين مضيفا
ان هذا الامر يستلزم تنفيذ كثيرا من
التحضيرات وتجهيز الاسس وخلال ثلاثه او
اربعه اشهر سنحدد خطواتنا لكننا مصر
التزمت الصمت ولم تدخل سباق التصريحات حول
هذه العلاقه بحسب مراقبين محللين قالوا ان
القاهره تريد افعالا لا اقوالا ما يعني ان
مصر تفضل اتباع النهج المتدرج المبني على
بنود محدده يحددها كبار المسؤول
علشان يتم الاصلاح بين مصر وتركيا ان هي
هتقف جنب مصر
وتقف جنب امن مصر وتساعد مصر على مقاومه
الارهاب والله تركيا في الظاهر اللي انا
شايفه من حوالي سنه تقريبا بتحاول تتودد
لمصر علشان خاطر مصلحتها فقط لا غير
خارج مصر المطلوبين همم المسابقه القضائيه
لازم يسلمو مبدئيا وبعد كده نتكلم في اي
احوال ثانيه خطوه كويسه ان هم حصل مقابله
بينهم وهي المفروض
تصلح العلاقات بين همم وكل العلاقات دول
المصريه على اعلى مستوى وممنوع ان تركيا
تتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه لمصر وتكون
علاقته جاريه اقتصاديه المفروض ان في
تعاون امني بحيث ان هم همم احنا نسلم
المطلوبين اللي عندنا عليهم وهم يسلمون
المطلوبين ويبقى في تعاون اقتصادي يساعد
بعض في الاقتصاد نظام التركي الحالي هو
يعمل
فهو على حسب مصلحته هيتم الاتفاق العلاقات
السياسيه معروفه ايه اللي مطلوب اعتقد
يعني الاداره التركيه عارفه ما يغضب مصر
وما يسعدها ما يسعدها هو التوافق في الرئه
التوافق في الرؤى المصريه التركيه
اذا تم محددات تريدها مصر قبل ان تخطوها
في هذه العلاقه تدريجيا عنوانها رفض رباعي
بحسب مراقبين الاول لا يمكن للقاهر القبول
باستمرار المرتزقه والقوات الاجنبيه على
الاراضي الليبيه على اعتبار ان ذلك يعد
مساسا بالامن القومي المصريه
لا يمكن القبول بشرعيه الاتفاقيات التي
وقعتها حكومات ليبيه سابقه او منتهيه
الولايه مع الجانب التركي وتسمح باجراءات
بعيده المدى دون توافق ليبيا كامل بشانها
اما الثالثه فلا عوده عن اتفاقيات ترسيم
الحدود البحريه التي وقعتها مصر مع كل من
اليونان وقبرص انطلاقا من كونها لحد نظرهم
مصدق عليها وتتفق مع مبادئ القانون الدولي
واتفاقيه الامم المتحده لقانون البحار عام
اخر لقاءات المصريه ثلج انها لا تقبل
المسافه بامن واستقرار وسياده كل من
اليونان وقبرص وان التقارب مع انقره لن
يكون على حساب العلاقات المتميزه مع اثينا
ونيقوسيا يشير الباحثون الى ان الوضع
الاقتصاديه في تركيا ومصر قد يدفع البلدين
الى اعطاء الاولويه للملف التجاري الذي
يعد اكثر سهوله في تحقيق قدر من التوافق
يمكن البناء عليه بعد ذلك بهدف التوصل الى
تنسيقات اهم سياسيا واميا
نحب الشعب المصري بيننا روابط تعود الى
العهد العثماني حتى بعد ذلك بقينا مرتبطين
ببعضنا هل هذا صحيح نعم كان هناك تباعد
بين الشعبين لان العلاقات السياسيه كانت
سيئه
العلاقات ونستطيع ايضا القيام بالتبادل
التجاري وتسويه الوضع الاقتصادي والتبادل
الاقتصادرات لماذا نبرم اتفاقيات مع دول
بعيده عنك الولايات المتحده وغيرها
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للعلاقات التركيه المصريه بدلا من
العلاقات مع الولايات المتحده وروسيا
برايي علاقتنا مع دول الجوار يجب ان تكون
افضل من علاقتنا مع الدول البعيده
المصريه التركيه
مهمه من الناحيه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
كشعبين لدينا روابط مشتركه من الناحيه
الدينيه تركيا ومصر مهمتان لبعضهما وفي
الاونه الاخيره حدث شيء غير متوقع وهو
لقاء الرئيسين السيسي واردوغان